Hunter has finally been charged after a
federal investigation into his countless
Financial sexual pharmaceutical and
Firearm related crimes and what was
Hunter charged with
two misdemeanor tax offenses and a gun
violation
that's all now even the minor charges
that Hunter ultimately faced could have
landed him in prison for a dozen years
but since Hunter pled guilty as part of
a deal with prosecutors he now faces uh
probation
probation for the tax charges and a
diversion program for the Firearms
charge a diversion program that he
doesn't even appear to be legally
eligible for that means that that latter
gun charge will likely be wiped from his
record sorry no prison no real
punishment no nothing